c'était le maestro de la pizza à
elancourt salvatore gambino plus connu
sous le nom de pino est décédé à 73 ans
le patron du restaurant la dolce vita
laisse orphelins des proches des amis et
de nombreux lots courtois puis nous
c'est un personnage d'une bonté émeutes
est très facile à comprendre
pinault est en cours et représentent des
piliers de la ville c'est un personnage
qui a fait naître un peu chaque quartier
par exemple il est la storia des locaux
et les restos les délinquants les pizzas
d'elancourt parce qu'avant il n'aime pas
les pid
il n'aime pas des pizzas comme ça comme
beaucoup riche d india beaucoup grain
ouverte depuis 1984 cette pizzeria est
une véritable institution fréquenté par
des célébrités comme le footballeur
nicolas anelka ou le comédien omar sy
ce dernier lui a rendu un hommage sur
les réseaux sociaux mais l'histoire va
continuer avec ses enfants lorenzo et
francesca gambino les buts et c'est ce
qu'il voulait c'est que le restaurant
est dure le plus longtemps possible et
on va tout faire pour que ça se sera le
plus longtemps possible pour toutes les
générations tous on travaille pour tout
ce qui est la règle
pourtant les sunlights mais c'est vrai
c'est l'institution
les pizzas de la dolce vita c'est une
institution les
et beaucoup de personnes ont grandi avec
sur même trois générations c'est des
choses qui sont des histoires qui sont
magnifiques
originaire de palerme qui nous est
arrivé en france en 1972 et il racontait
souvent son histoire à ses enfants
il parlait pas un mot de français il
avait 100 francs dans la poche
il dormait dans les voitures ouvertes à
gare de lyon quand il est arrivé
et voilà ce que la bâtie voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé avec ses deux
bras toujours
dans la rigueur du travail dans la
négation du travail les élans courtois
auront l'occasion de rendre hommage à
salvatore gambino le mardi 20 juillet à
14h30 à l'église saint médard pour
saluer une dernière fois la dolce vita
de pino le sicilien le plus connu
d'elancourt